why must you be apologetic for being a
black African child in South Africa hops
opposed to being cross learning but
ended up fighting I'm fighting to be me
why the protest comes after black girls
from Pretoria girls high were allegedly
asked not to wear the hair naturally not
to speak in the mother tongue and not to
congregate on the school grounds that's
why the hashtag has sparked outrage on
social media cokato moiety a South
African social activist supports the
girls fight and has started a petition
to focus attention on the protest
unthinkable that in 2016 we need to have
young children that are fighting for the
humanity so we owe it to them to Utley
stand in solidarity but also to protect
them and ensure that they are not
victimized for standing up and saying
enough is enough
we do not want to be creating members of
society who need to recover from their
childhood people who are traumatized
from the unthinkable circumstances that
they deal with so it's about much more
than here but we cannot ignore that he
is one of the manifestations of this
racism there's also unthinkable that
battles that our parents thought many
years ago I saw bit relevant today are
sobbing for today it didn't it is a
tragedy you know it is a huge tragedy